nobody wants to host the Golden Globes
anymore they ask Chris Rock and he
didn't want to do it they ask Tina Fay
and she didn't want to do it until they
finally got to this guy who who's a name
is Joe Koy Oppenheimer answered a
lifelong question that's been on my mind
for years yes scientists do get
laid as long as they look like Killian
Murphy the big difference between the
Golden Globes and the NFL on the Golden
Globes we have fewer camera shots of
Taylor Swift I swear there just where to
go too here so the joke is not funny
it's tired and lame but Swift isn't
really reacting like it's a corny joke
like she's she's visibly mad about it
she's offended by that joke and that's
why Joe Koy is doing this and not Ricky
J these people cannot stand even the
gentlest bit of teasing